TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello
I'm, Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We recently announced the second
annual Google Play Indie Games
Contest in Europe, expanding
to more countries and bigger
prizes.
The contest rewards your
passion, creativity,
and innovation and
provides support
to help bring your
game to more people.
Head on over to the post
linked in the description
below for more details on
prizes and how to enter.
In the category of "Too
Cool Not To Mention"
is our recent open source
release for quantum computers.
OpenFermion is the first
open source platform
for translating problems
in chemistry and materials
science into quantum
circuits that can be
executed on existing platforms.
A lot more detail can
be found on the post.
To help further research into
human action recognition,
we've released a new data set
that provides multiple action
labels for each person in
extended video sequences.
The data set consists of URLs
for publicly available videos
from YouTube, annotated with
a set of 80 atomic actions,
such as walk or shake hands.
And these are
spatial-temporally localized,
resulting in over 57,000
video segments, 96,000 labeled
humans performing actions, and a
total of 210,000 action labels.
Examples, charts, and a
link to download the data
are on the post.
Keeping sensitive and
regulated data private
can be a challenge.
The Data Loss Prevention
API can help you quickly
find and protect over 50
types of sensitive data,
such as credit card numbers,
names, and national ID numbers.
And there are several new
ways to protect sensitive data
with the DLP API including
redaction, masking,
and tokenization.
Check out the post
for all the details.
The Google Cloud Platform
Cloud Launcher Marketplace
provides production-grade
solutions
that you can launch and
manage in just a few clicks.
Click to deploy solutions
further lower operational costs
with open source products
that are maintained by Google.
We recently launched
21 new VM solutions
for some of the most popular
open source products,
including node.js the
Ruby Stack and MySQL.
Get started with the post.
With the launch
of the iPhone 10,
you need to plan for new
design considerations
as the rounded corners,
notch, and screen indicator
on the extended screen can
obscure content and lead
to poor ad experiences
for users when
ads are placed in these areas.
Which is why we've
put together a guide
to help you adapt your ad
strategy for iPhone 10, which
you can get by visiting the
post linked in the description
below.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of the Developer Show.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
they're right over here--
on the right side
of your screen.
There.
[MUSIC PLAYING]